hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Alana
Alana cole is back coolest gay girl on
YouTube and that's right oh that's right
what sure you're the gay guest I am NOT
homophobic proving you're wrong right
now I don't think anyone thought it was
anyway um for the longest [ __ ] time
there's been this video out since 2014
that people have been asking me to check
out and I was like fine I'll do it
since I'm getting so many requests for
it john cena prank call I wasn't really
looking forward to doing this cuz I was
like you can't really have a discussion
out of it it's just a reaction but
whatever whatever let's see uh young
John Cena is I don't he's a wrestler
he's this guy right here you see him
he's pretty buff he's pretty buff does
he make you want to be straight oh no
not with his mouth open like that that's
how he would eat you out yeah that's
kind of scary
this tongues not even there is a salty
yeah our ass dudes let's hear what's so
funny
just this week's phone scam check it out
Wow
I have just one question for you are you
ready
am I ready for what okay are you ready
for this Sunday night
John Cena defends his title and the WWE
right now we cover this awesome
pay-per-view of it for just $59.99 I'm
sorry no there is not any chance in hell
that we're ever gonna thank you but no
okay Wow
and goodbye to anyone standing at John
Cena's in a steel cage chutes and
ladders match WWE soon ordered I would
say $10 the place of just $49.99 30
vices called me and as I mentioned
before we're not ordering this - please
stop calling my house page one to five
hi can I speak to champ no champ is
champ there who can that questionable
the answer
Hey calling me hello I'm watching you
that's exactly what the Undertaker told
history the wrestling no Superman class
is happening in it there is no more I
swear to Jesus this is wrestling again
okay good morning hi I'm just pulling
this morning to ask if your supporter of
the United States military oh my god I
apologize we've been getting calls all
morning I apologize and yes yeah I am
great are you a supporter of the Marine
Corps yes absolutely
good great because a former decorated
member of the United States Marine Corps
needs your support and his name is Josh
hello you have a will you accept the
charges
won't be allowed in Italy here in this
house he's going through the closets
taking out t-shirts and leaving them
there to go into police and tell me what
you're asking me stupid now just kind of
calling the police
good luck to you have a nice day hold on
Marie Marie this is the Z morning zoo
Mugsy 104 how are you what we've been
doing we've been folks okay thank you
your your husband died
believe the mouse thought you had are
you oh my god listen um I haven't I have
another confidence yeah I know listen we
won't be calling you back anymore I
promise okay thank you whatever you want
to do this listen I was I can go to jail
and I was can I go to jail I was gonna
go directly to the jail and be like you
need to put this person in here would
you be all crazy oh this reminds me of
um this time this guy texted me like
non-stop for like months and I was like
dude I'm gonna call the cops on you you
need to you just need to go he kept
asking me out it was like no no no well
why did you say no that woman was losing
her [ __ ] yeah it's so funny how some
people really can't take a prank phone
call I just would stop answering yeah I
felt like her ego was up and she just
needed to [ __ ] fight I felt like she
was taking out something on these prank
callers man like she kind of enjoyed it
because she could take out her anger
yeah I'm like why the [ __ ] else would
you keep answering and chewing these
people out don't you know you're just
giving them what they want like if you
if you give them that reaction and you
keep calling you keep answering you're
just gonna you're gonna get the reaction
you want but I don't know I thought it
was kind of cool why she was cool at the
end about it yeah you know she's like
you just haven't had my coffee yeah they
had great excuse I would love to be
around that woman when she doesn't have
coffee coffee is scary luckily I don't
drink coffee also know what happened to
me I don't drink coffee either
I gotta weed snort a lot of coke shoot a
lot of heroin but I don't drink coffee
yeah you know I stick with tea out of
all those options her that's not very
good for you he isn't yeah that's not
very good for you classic cocaine is the
way to go oh that's
a lot better oh yeah I know you just
take a little whiff of that energy spike
through the roof you get a lot done
combine it with an adderall you're set
for the day you're set for the day and
night and night yeah you don't even you
sleep I haven't slept in like two years
that's scary I've been taking cocaine
for two years pretty scary yeah I think
I could produce so many videos anyway
guys thanks for tuning in to the Chanel
if you're new to it you can subscribe to
the real rejects you can check out a la
Nicole's channel really great youtuber
you really feel like you're connecting
with her when you watch your videos it's
it's really good and there's a lot of
gay themes going on right now not saying
that just because she's gay I'm just
pointing out a fact and we just did a
video for Alana's channel pulled a
couple of phone pranks this is the john
cena prank call a figure we'll do our
own pranks here's a little snippet of
how one of them went down hi um I'm with
my girlfriend right now and she's
telling me that one of your waiters
groped her breasts thank you and you can
follow both of us on facebook instagram
twitter i'm at two real ryan writes on
instagram and twitter and Alana's at oh
I wanna have C oh yes it's an H cuz my
name is Alana with an H and I have a
vine and periscope too and she has a
periscope that she never uses but if she
gets enough attractive females to
subscribe to her channel she will
definitely use her a periscope more I I
now agree to that I guess after yeah
yeah I gotta admit like you're you're
not a typical looking gay person I meet
that's in LA it was a girl really yeah
what do they normally look like um not
to sound sexist homophobic
I don't know which one how about how
about I say it and you tell me which one
it is
okay um they normally look like they're
definitely a lesbian
like it snapped back I don't know it's
like you could just tell is all kinds of
lesbian looks but I'm like you look like
a like I would guess you're a lesbian
and I would be right okay I think that
uh neither sexist or homophobic
I don't just ignorance and judgment yeah
just being judgmental towards people so
Karen so how are we all are we all